[Music]
i'm very glad that the leaders were able
to agree in principle
on the six
sanctions package
this is very important thanks to this
council should now be able to finalize a
ban on almost 90 percent of all russian
oil imports by the end of the year this
is an important step forward
now left over is the around about 10 or
11 percent
that are covered by the
southern uh douchebag
and indeed here we have agreed agreed
this is for the moment being exempted we
have agreed to uh that the council will
revert to the topic as soon as possible
in one way or the other
so
this is a topic where we will come back
to
and uh where we will still have to work
on but it is a big step forward what we
did today
so this is good that we now de-swift the
spare bank
there is a ban on insurance and
reinsurance of russian ships by eu
companies
a ban on providing russian companies
with a whole range of business services
and very important the suspension of
broadcasting in the european union of
three further russian state outlets um
that were
very typically
spreading broadly the misinformation
that we have witnessed over the last
weeks and months
you